So as we've seen Donald Trump second impeachment
trial get in day two and then now into day three,
there have been a lot of questions about
just what has Donald Trump actually been
doing these last few days and even the
couple of weeks since he left office.
And there's a very interesting new article
in The Washington Post from Josh Dossi and
Ashley Parker that tells the story of Donald
Trump at Mar a Lago in Palm Beach, Florida,
doing a lot of golfing, not surprisingly,
doing a lot of just calling old friends and
trying to reconnect with people. He reportedly
continues to have many political aides on his
payroll just around him, sycophants of sorts of
different kinds. But this Washington Post article
really tells the story of a former president and
former sort of big shot businessman, at least,
at least to some degree, whose world is really
crumbling around him, increasingly isolated
from most of the of popular culture, half the
country, or more disgusted with him, unwilling
to patronize his businesses anymore. And while,
as Josh Dossey writes in The Washington Post,
Trump is confident that he is going to be
acquitted. He is increasingly disturbed
partially by the absolutely bizarre performance
of his attorney, Bruce Castor, on Monday,
the free association Rorschach test sort of thing
that took place, which we covered yesterday. Trump
disappointed in Bruce Caster's performance. Donald
Trump also reportedly not pleased in general with
how Republicans have been. Some Republicans have
been responding to the evidence presented so far.
And Donald Trump is in this sort of bubble. And
we know that Donald Trump was in a bubble while he
was president of the United States. But he seems
to sort of further be protecting himself with this
bubble. And part of it, interestingly enough,
is coming from the fact that Donald Trump is
banned from a lot of social media platforms where
Donald Trump not banned from Twitter right now.
He would be not only tweeting, but also spending
more time on Twitter and maybe seeing that there
are even many Republicans disgusted with Donald
Trump's role in inciting the riots on January
6th. The fact that Donald Trump has been removed
from Twitter and a number of other platforms
has placed him in what many people around him are
saying. It is a state of being adrift. No idea of
what to do day to day, no idea of what comes next
and whether there is a future for Donald Trump's
political life and business life. And I think this
is another aspect that it just sort of remains to
be seen like this. Donald Trump go back to doing
real estate deals at this point. The one thing
that has been mentioned by a number of sources
that Dorsey and Parker cite in The Washington
Post piece is that Donald Trump is calmer
than was expected. He was reportedly screaming
about Bruce Caster's terrible performance. But
Trump seems relatively calm as he is adrift and
unclear about what the future is of his business
and political life. But Donald Trump reportedly
furious with some Republicans, including
Congresswoman Liz Cheney, who did vote to impeach
Donald Trump in the House of Representatives.
House Republican leader Kevin McCarthy, who said
Trump does have some responsibility for the attack
on the Capitol, then ended up backtracking when
those comments exploded. So the general sense
here is that this is a Trump surrounded by
the most extreme sycophants, because who else
would be left at this point to even be around
Donald Trump, given what's taken place off social
media, partially because he's been kicked off,
furious with the Republicans that he believes have
abandoned him and unclear as to what the future of
his life even is at this point in time.
Now, one other interesting detail about
Donald Trump during the impeachment
trial and in the days leading up
early on, you'll remember that a bunch of Donald
Trump's lawyers for the second impeachment trial
quit. It was, I guess, a week ago Sunday,
not this past Sunday, but the previous one.
Part of what we believe led to that is that
Donald Trump was insisting to his first legal team
that they defend Trump in the impeachment trial
by arguing that Trump's claims about a stolen
election were were true. This is sort of like an
affirmative defense. If you're accused of killing
someone and you're being charged with murder,
one defense would be I didn't do it either.
I didn't kill anybody. An affirmative defense
would be I did kill them. But it's not murder
because it was self-defense. And what Donald Trump
wanted was the affirmative defense of, OK, yeah,
I did tell people to go to the capital and they
were being inspired by me, but it was because
I rightly identified that the election was stolen
from me. Trump's initial. Defense team reportedly
thought that that was an absolutely terrible idea,
knowing Donald Trump's instinct for self sabotage
and inflicting, you know, unforced, unforced
problems upon himself. They didn't go with that.
And Donald Trump ultimately getting new lawyers.
But that is not the case that is being made in
the case that we we have already seen previewed
by Donald Trump's attorneys, Bruce Castor and
David Schoen, and which we are going to continue
to see today. And as the the defense mounts are
simply that Donald Trump didn't incite the riot
period and that another source of isolation and
fury and confusion from Donald Trump. So I don't
know what the future of Donald Trump's life is.
What I hope happens is that the country can move
on from Trump. But at the same time and we're
going to talk about this on the Friday show,
I do actually hope for the sake of the left
that Donald Trump tries to start a third party
because so many Republicans have said in surveys
that they'd be willing to abandon the Republican
Party and follow Trump Trump starting a third
party. It could be exactly what the left needs
to really make some progress over the next two,
four, six, even eight years. So we'll be
talking more about that on tomorrow's program.